in the game of geopolitics
and historic move
today finland's prime minister and
president jointly supported joining nato
without delay
a plan many in the capital helsinki are
backing
earlier if you would have asked me i i
thought
that nathan was becoming kind of an
anti-russian alliance
but then
turns out we need an anti-russian
alliance so
i used to be against it but after the
war in ukraine i'm like
very much for it
how do you feel about joining nato well
turning into to finland is a good thing
finland is a very small country and we
definitely need
nato to defend ourselves the war in
ukraine has directly influenced
finland's change of heart before the
invasion around 20 of people here
supported joining nato
now the majority are in favor
why now for joining nato
the security environment has changed a
lot in the europe and now it's the right
time for the finland
to join the nato
with more than 280 000 troops and 900
000 reservists finland would add serious
firepower to the alliance
the kremlin is considering its next move
saying it will be forced to take
retaliatory steps it could be
potentially some kind of hybrid threats
like cyber threats for instance there
might be some energy supply issues for
instance or we might see also some kind
of
violation of airspace and we had those
over the years already
joining nato offers extra protection but
membership isn't instant and that's
where friends like britain come in
yesterday boris johnson pledging to have
finland's back in a fight
what's happening here is a serious own
goal for vladimir putin russia's
aggression means it could soon have two
new nato neighbours with both finland
and sweden expected to announce they're
officially joining in the next few days
the war in ukraine has been a game
changer with russia becoming
increasingly isolated
siobhan robbins sky news in helsinki
finland